welcome back to the 16th ever episode of
the
iced coffee hour thank you for tuning in
today we have a
wonderful guest cassie de pekel
correct why don't you say your last name
how about you do that way to go
that was really good though like you
just spaced it out a little too much but
otherwise okay how would you how would
you it's depecle
yeah wait what do
yeah welcome to the show so really
exciting guests look at this you brought
you brought books for us
so you're your thing you have been to
every single
country in the world every single one of
the countries
a lot of countries and even uh i i would
say this is this is
what what shocked me not not that not
that that was naked and afraid
you forgot yeah yeah naked and afraid
yeah i used to love that show
and you were in one of the episodes i
don't know if we could put a clip up
here for copyright reasons so we could
just leave this to be searched
but uh yeah but anyway but you traveled
the world
just all on your own yeah okay so where
do we even
i don't even know where to begin i have
a feeling that's probably the most
interesting let's talk about that then
we'll talk about naked and afraid yeah
i'm
definitely willing to dive deep into
either okay or both at the same time
let's
let's do both uh we'll start with
traveling the world
why for how feasible that because you do
that for free right
how much how much does it cost you let's
talk about cost first oh god
right in deep with the money aspect um
yeah so essentially before this whole
thing long story short i was like a
babysitter not even nanny
babysitting so making i don't know
like around like 40 35
somewhere around there so i started this
business
it was actually the idea stemmed from
sitting in the dirt
in a fetal position dirt like during it
getting afraid in the jungle
but um it started from like a really
weird space
but um i yeah it was it was uh
you know created the whole idea and i
thought all right it's gonna be around
created the budget sorry i'm kind of
jumping around how do you create a
budget whatever
how many are in legal positions
in my head and i'm like so you did you
did naked and afraid
first yes before okay so yeah that's
where the idea came but
getting on naked and afraid to begin
with how do you qualify for that what
are the qualifications for getting on
the show to begin with because you have
to have it back they're not going to let
me go on naked and afraid there's nobody
say that
because i wouldn't last one night i mean
there's no air conditioning out there
there's no heater out there no
nothing no there's no tempurpedic
mattress i can't how am i supposed to so
they have to make sure you're hardcore
so they do and like essentially when i
was growing up i was homeschooled a lot
growing up
on and off so we did we had a guy come
to the house and do like survival stuff
and then i went to green mountain
college in vermont and
i also did survival stuff there so i'm
like i think i can survive
you know so i'm gonna go ahead and i was
working at a pyramid scheme
door-to-door business-to-business sales
job for like verizon
pyramids game like total i was verizon
appeared it was terrible
it was it was like someone who's like it
was like this company they
they say they're their own company but
they're actually not like they have no
affiliation with verizon
and they're trying to sell all their
like phones and wi-fi what was it called
businesses
are you allowed to say i don't know like
they're going to come back
should i i don't know it's called
potomac advisory group and it was in
alexandria virginia
all right and i think they're closed now
and they're like they just fired me and
like they didn't give me unemployment
and like whatever and like they was for
no re whatever anyways okay
um and so yeah i was just sitting on my
couch one day i was like i hate my life
and then i just saw these like naked
people running across the tv screen
i was like what are they doing and
they're like in the jungle that you know
what
i think it's time like my life is is
kind of bad i feel like i'm at my rock
bottom at the moment so i'm gonna go
ahead and just do it so you wanted to
run naked across the tv and i was like
you know what
maybe that might be my thing you know so
i just like filled in an application i
didn't know what it was for
you know until i was filling it out
they're like you have to survive like
naked in the jungle
it's like 21 days and i'm like all right
well i'm still going to do it because i
do have some survival
skills you know from homeschooling in
college and
sure enough surviving home school yeah
surviving college
so okay so you submit the application
how much longer until they get back to
you
uh it was a couple weeks or so and then
like they had the preliminary like we're
interested
and then it was like oh it was a matter
of like
i want to say two months and then they
flew me out to la i was still in dc at
the time
and uh yeah and they just they kind of
had me like
go through the process here and i was
pretty much in
what's the process do they ask you to
get naked
no no it was like they had you do like
uh like
like a psychology like sex tests make
sure you're like mentally sane
and just like ask they that you had to
like do some tests with like a
survivalist and make sure you knew what
you were talking about
um it was pretty easy but it was
honestly they were looking for the
villain
i think of that of that season that we
were on
yeah i was how are you the villain so
it's like
they have i feel like even with reality
tv they have the characters
i've learned over the years and i was on
a special with like four people instead
of two
so um i was that young blonde ditz
bee okay of a of a contestant
okay um and who didn't know what she was
doing so i'm an introvert and i love
working
alone like not with a team you know i'm
like i'm a hard worker but like alone
and it's the same thing that with you
know with naked and afraid i was just
doing a lot of work but i was doing it
alone and
the team didn't like that because they
wanted me to work with them did you make
it all the way to the end
i did yeah what do you win nothing
absolutely nothing
there's a cash prize there's a little
tiny cash prize so you guys
still can't say to this day oh you can't
okay tiny little touch
wow but you would but you would think
that that would require people to take
30 days how we know how how many days is
that
21 21 days and they wanted me to go back
for the 40
42 day like double the time wow then you
didn't go back
i was like well i guess publicity
right i mean it's like a mill yeah well
i mean not even like because like
the people who watch that kind of show
it's like
they're kind of like well i mean in
general generally speaking like
graham watching right now i mean i did
two obviously like i found out about it
from watching it but like generally
speaking it's like
people who like redneck america i feel
like okay not to be
judgmental but i want you to anyone who
watches the show
this is nice directed towards you and i
have friends who watch it too but
you know generally speaking i feel like
i don't know if the audience would
really help
honestly it hasn't really helped me
because they've all been like
you suck you're this you're that it's
like all negative and i'm like
i'm sure but so you were on the show and
that gave you the inspiration to travel
every country yeah really i yeah let's
talk
logistics of the show for a second um
how do you for like how do you use the
restroom
do you just or how do you like do you
eat good questions you have to hunch
do you have to hunt for your food yeah
thankfully my partner was good at that i
got the snails in the river
but with the bathroom um the ocean
so like one big misconception was like
they would see us like laying on rocks
specifically just me like like as if i
was tanning like
using this time to tan my body like
trying to survive on a rock but it's
like you go in the ocean
you take a you know you piss i don't
know if you want me to swear on this or
no
no swearing no or or if you do
it yeah okay yeah so you go one and two
in the ocean
and then you just like gotta lay off to
dry because then you have to go back to
work in the
in the jungle again we were on a beach
ocean thing so that's when we would most
do it is in the ocean
like to answer what about brushing teeth
um
no like sometimes you would take some
like leaves like
coconut leaves or whatever but no yeah
not really right so it was actually so
naked and afraid is actually
not legit yeah it's totally okay because
i always was under the impression that
those shows they provide you with like
toilet paper
toothbrushes deodorant even like tampons
they didn't they do oh like i feel like
they have to
otherwise like what are you gonna do sit
in your tent and like what are you gonna
do yeah
yeah right yeah nothing else though
that's like the extent of it okay
i mean even like contacts and i had like
solution but i had to like wash it with
my dirty hands
really oh yeah like nothing like wow
yeah
and what if you were gonna eat a snail
that was like poisonous or something
like what is it
so if they see something like they're
crawling in poison ivy they're just
yeah so if a bear comes up to you and is
going to maul you
then they'll probably try and break that
apart if it were that if that were the
case but like one of the producers like
on my special it was
the season one double jeopardy special
and
the producer on that show like um when
they were preparing for this episode
he was they were scoping out areas or
whatever and he got bit by
um what kind of what kind of stink a
coral snake i think it was
and he had to go to the hospital i mean
his whole leg i mean he ended up okay
but it was like
super intense you know those were the
jungles that we were like dealing with
you know
huh so you literally just survived in
the wild as if
it was like 2 000 years ago yeah
probably what do you do for drinking
water
um thankfully to one of my
teammates they found like a little sip
thing like a sieve a sieve
not a separative like coming from a rock
and so we'd fill that with like coke
like we found like coconut
filled the coconut bowl with with that
water how do you eat in our lucky did
you lose a ton of weight or something
during that
yeah i mean i lost 14 pounds my partner
lost like 28 pounds
i mean so you could only do that for
about three weeks before your body
i would imagine it starts to shut down
yeah
i just can't like i don't know how to do
that teeth is just what keeps sewing up
it's like you would do it
if you could brush your teeth yeah yeah
like do you go to the dentist like
come on go to the gym
i did make like clothing out of like
coconut husk like i made a bra and like
you know like a little skirt thing and
um
my teammates were like we need that to
make a fire tonight i was like oh but
can you find something else
and i'll help you because i don't want
to give up my class and then in front of
the
you know film people and i just had to
like take that bra what was that
like uh getting because i know the
beginning of the show it's like you just
straight up see the other person you're
both naked
was there any embarrassment with that or
like
the very my situation like everyone said
everyone's situation is different but
mine
uh his name was forrest and he's
actually from santa barbara okay
he's from i think he was like zimbabwe
originally but like he lives in santa
barbara
and he just like you know we got off
this boat
walked towards each other he put his
hands in the air and just started
shaking
his thing is that no when you met with
it was that actually
the first time you met very first time
we met and i was just like looking at
him like
coming at me like dancing and shaking
his thing and i was just like
better that than like really
embarrassing no i think
i think that'd be better yeah and the
show okay because you don't know it
could go either it could go either way
like
it's not funny like it's not funny but i
have to laugh because and i'm on tv so
yeah it's a little weird i mean if that
was like
in the open in public that would be yeah
that would yeah
because you don't know what type of
person you're getting when they do that
it could either be trying to ease
attention
or if you're a little like that's like
actually a person
yeah crazy person dominance
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah i'm not gonna speak further on that
one wow the answer to it but
yeah that was um that was that was we
didn't get along yeah okay
you and forest yeah we did okay um
but you know it is it is what it is and
at the end of the day we we still kind
of talk like manu and i want to one of
my partners
we all still talk now we're just kind of
like life in our way but
we were totally fine and happy at the
end like all of us
friends and stuff but during it you
would never think that
so was one of the first things that you
did was just find clothes i would assume
uh first thing was the shelter so yeah
okay that makes sense and then i was
like all right i'm gonna make some like
pull a leaf over
over myself just like tie a leaf with
some there's so much
we were in a really good spot like if
you were in the middle of like
the african like sub-saharan desert or
whatever there would be like nothing
you know to like make anything out of
but we were in kind of the jungle beach
so there were some coconut trees coconut
husks
to make stuff out of but yeah the
shelter was really important and we
didn't agree on that
on how to do it what was the first thing
you did after the show like what was the
first thing you ate
or you put clothes on what was that like
brush the teeth
yeah i made a video first of all like
looking disgusting no
no teeth brushed for my instagram um
and and then they had like a huge
smorgasbord of like like like pork rinds
and like all this like
everything you could ask for essentially
and beer so i think the first sip i had
was like a beer
really you wouldn't want just like water
yeah i would do that like arrowhead
okay so into the sauna yeah that's a
good point
and a helicopter when they rescued like
when we got to the helicopter they gave
us like
those um those granola like new tree
bars like
or whatever and water so that was the
first thing
and then we had the uh whole you know
smorgasbord but yeah right
and then what about when you got home
what was the first like would you want a
mcdonald's
i'd get a big mac oh yeah yeah you got
to do a big mac
this is really bringing me back yeah um
or sushi yeah oh my gosh i think it
i think it was probably like sushi or
something like
uh something with my family i don't
remember something like i don't
yeah i just stuffed myself i gained it
all back in like a week
and how how about sleeping could you
sleep well there no
not not at all so you were basically
always tired yeah i'm guessing always
always and what were your turns like oh
wow
wow so how do you wake up i guess you
would wake up
how do you know what time it is i don't
know they just like you know you just
kind of like
all right like i'm about to fall asleep
so can you please just take over
and then we'd like take turns watching
the fight miserable it was
totally and it was pouring rain yeah 50
55 degrees you know like freezing
you know rain falling on you there were
there were little hermit crabs crawling
all over us
oh gosh oh yeah we're like oh oh don't
move
there's something i was like okay
there's something that was the one
wow yeah there was something they were
little ants there was
you know snakes so what does that make
you feel now when you
you go home and like you're in a house
i'm so still has this had an impact even
to this day it's like just to have a
kitchen
yes okay yes and i live in a very tiny
home
like it's like 480 square feet
and it's into a paint like really really
small and i'm just like you know what
i'm so grateful for this right now like
this is all i could ask for i don't want
to you know
you never know what makes sense yeah
there's
one more thing i'm just wildly curious
about what would you eat like what was
what was i'm sure that there were common
things that you just continued to eat
because it was readily available
so i was gonna say something and then i
was like yeah yeah what was it yeah
so there were there are these monkeys
that would like kind of open up these
berries like chew the stuff outside the
berries and like throw them on the
ground or throw the bad ones on the
ground
and so uh minou and i would actually go
out and collect these berries that these
monkeys just kind of like
worked yeah and like open and like threw
on the ground and we would eat those
um so like a lot of those berries from
the monkeys
um a lot of snails from the river i
thought you were about to see the monkey
like you know they had these monkeys and
it tastes like good we killed an
armadillo
like the very very first week that we
yeah
very first week we were there it was
just him and i and he was like all right
cassie make the fire i'm like all right
here's my time to shine
how did you do it what how do you do it
he just like
he saw it he put his hand over the neck
and just
he had a little spear then oh yeah i'd
have too hard of a time
doing that though i mean i guess if
you're really hungry
armadillo is like was it good the
disease you can cr like catch from that
i forget what it's called like what is
it called
even if it's in manila no it's something
it's it's something it's like a disease
that lasts with you for a long time oh
god
um but yeah i couldn't make the fire so
it wasn't did it taste good that one
that one you didn't i didn't make the
fire
and so he was very angry and so and i
was chewing wait wait wait wait wait you
eat it
no because we had to cook it we have to
cook it yeah so what did you just say
you just let it sit there yeah we let it
sit there i know
well i none of uh neither one of us
could make the fire like we could
because it was so damp over there like
yeah
and everything with that but i will say
though the last one the last night we
had to trek like four days through the
jungle
across the ocean and right to the
extraction point points
i remember that it was across the ocean
filled with sharks
yeah and he caught us all like lobster
he was he went gung-ho he caught us
lobster this is forest
that was when it all came to fruition
for him like his whole
you know what he'd been working for it
actually just he just caught it all and
he worked really hard to catch that
stuff and i'm like i feel bad
but he shared it equally whatever wow
and we did eat the hermit crabs
put those over the fire and just do you
how do you eat a hermit crab
is it just the the belly that goes in
the the thing it's like the whole crab
and then you just eat the shells just
chomp on it shell and everything i don't
think it's how you do it in the modern
world but that's right i guess you would
have to do that but you just chew it
what was the weirdest thing you ate um
in general or just like like in the show
in the show and then in general some
funky stuff
um
wow i don't know i mean i would say
probably those
monkey droppings because we're not for
sure where those came from
you know like with the snails from that
little river like we
like you know that those are snails
coming from the river we ate oysters off
the rock we like chucked them off
with a sword or machete but
um i would just say the monkey dropping
it's not really that like intense
um and then in general uh chicha and the
amazon
i don't know what's that early travels
what is that all right so
in the deep within the amazon which you
guys you guys gotta go
you get the chances of amazon yes deep
within so like
these ladies in the little communities
like the community that i went to she
would like
chew on this like root and it would
create
chicha i forget the name of the room
don't ask my memory is terrible but i
remember shoot they would like chew on
this root they would spit it into this
like wooden bowl and then they'd mix it
with the water from the river
and then they'd let it sit into the in
the sun and ferment
into this beer and they'd feed it to all
the guys in the community after they
played soccer you know
um and then they fed it to all of us so
there'd be like kind of white stuff
you're not sure and it's like a
fermented
and it kind of also is like a beer so it
also makes you feel like a little bit so
you're like what's going on
so someone choose that the ladies the
little old ladies like who don't really
like the teeth are kind of missing but
it ferments
but it ferments yeah kind of gets rid of
that how much do they have to chew to
get like a like a drinkable
i'd imagine it for one route it's like
one big stock will get like one drink
and how many jars and is it like a drink
per person yeah
and how long does it take to do it chew
a whole route like
sit there and just like our grandmas
will sit and knit like all day like yeah
issue in the room do they get paid for
it
no they just do it wait what they're
they're
they're the little old ladies in the
community who just like love to support
their families and
what if they're ill well then they don't
do it yeah
wait hold on why don't you just chew
your own sticks
yeah that's a good that's a good one
drink someone else's chewed it's family
like if your grandma made this sort of
drink for you no i wouldn't
absolutely not i mean if you didn't know
any better
like you knew better though i don't
think the guys in the
family they know where it's coming from
though it's not a surprise
here's this mystery drink with white
chunks it's like
and they actually feed it to you so like
you have to drink it like you're not
just like taking you're like i'll just
take a little
no they actually put it into your mouth
like they feed it they
look part of accepting like food you
know like with all
with with with moms and ladies of like
communities like
accepting the food is so important
because i want you to
actually consume the food and accept it
and like
wait do they put it in your mouth or do
they they'll actually just like
oh my gosh wow what happens if you're to
gag
like you do yeah what happened
disrespectful
that's just what it is okay
what does it taste like it was
absolutely disgusting really
yeah it was very disgusting that's what
i would yeah but what does it take like
what oh
god i can't even it was so long ago uh
it was
um fermented imagine like ferment
something that's fermented
um okay and it had like a tang and also
like a
weird earthy flavor to it like very
earthy
almost like dirt because it kind of was
okay that's what it tasted like
essentially like a dirt earthy
weird okay kind of
like that drink i had in yeah i was
confused how people invent that like who
thought yeah like i'm going to chew this
i'm going to ferment it i'm going to
leave it out and then i'm going to drink
it
and then i'm going to start it off with
some weird guy that like wanted
some girl to do that no oh no
so i don't i don't get how some of this
stuff is invented that's what i want to
know like who's the first guy to make
this and how did he share this with his
with his buds yeah there was a drink i
also had in
vanuatu too where they like what's that
um
drink or the vanuatu it's a country in
the pacific
kind of near australia i guess it's the
closest kind of country jack's never
left california
oh no i've left california
[Laughter]
otherwise it's a huge disc and they'll
become angry at you and they won't
they won't want to host you anymore okay
yeah um
but this is cava it was called cava oh
i've never heard of that
i've heard yeah they have that was big
in fiji yeah they have yeah they have it
over there too yeah yeah for sure
and i feel like in la they'll they have
some some of that coming over
the cava root it's supposed to be good
for you yeah it's it's kind of not in
like high quality quantities or whatever
um but like the guys like right they
invited me into their like little shack
and then they just like grinded it
and they just like essentially mix it
with water i was like i made a video on
it i was like
mix it with water you mix it with water
and then you drink it and it's like kind
of like
the effect of like weed effect or
marijuana
chill or whatnot um but as opposed to
like marijuana
cabba is not good in like high quality
like if you take it for a while it's
like it
wreaks havoc on your system really i
know i don't think they know about it
it's like something that needs to be
more educated over there
that was yeah but the
yes the amazonian experience was
that that was probably the food wise cam
what is the worst thing you've ever
tasted um
i think i had like a human finger no you
didn't
i almost believed that for that i'm like
you wouldn't do you went to the amazon
oh don't they
really have cannibals
no that's in the philippines is that
really they in the
in the mountains in the philippines they
have they had cannibalism therefore did
you steal that
no i did not okay did not i was really
sick in papua new guinea actually
wow okay uh jackfruit which we have here
right now
tasty to meat jackfruit it tastes
it tastes really foul i don't like it
tastes foul a berry fowl that sounds
like it's just
really good fruit here though vegan meat
if you go to like whole foods you'll see
it okay
um essentially it's like a
big prickly thing and like they shave it
and it's kind of oh yeah
i've seen the big yeah the yellow things
with the bricks on them yeah
exactly okay and so like i would eat
that in a lot like in central america
and stuff smells tasty
that's it yes that's what it is okay you
see these grocery stores and stuff
i'm not very picky like i pretty much
eat everything
i know it's not that exciting so you
traveled everywhere let's go let's go to
this now
okay so you were in the fetal position
and you decided every country
how many countries have you been to
prior to that
um i've been to around 25 or so 24
26 somewhere in between there and that
was between the ages of 18
and 23 essentially
how did you pay for that before yes okay
uh i had
it was bootstrapping like nothing
i had a blog i'd make like a little bit
of money off of that like a hundred
bucks a month
and that would i was able to afford my
next ticket to the next country
but essentially i would utilize like
helpex and
uh work away and i would just get free
room and board for like months at a time
and they provide me like
like food and a place to sleep and some
of them would provide me a little bit of
cash
and i would just utilize that to get to
the next place what what sort of work
so like backing up a little tiny touch
because i feel like this makes no sense
if i don't like
you have to start off with like a little
bit so i was around like 20
and you know saved up like 2 500 bucks
and
you know my brother and i took off that
that you know september
and he had more than i did but that he
ended up cutting it up off short
that whole trip but i was like a lot you
know i was able to make it last around
two years with that
you know 2500 and i
i ended up making some money along the
way with that
yeah so you were mentioning like blogs
but what's the work the work from home
thing or the work thing
mm-hmm where you could live for free and
just work yeah what sort of work were
you doing
like i would literally find the most
luxurious like hotel in the area
and one of them was like in machu picchu
that's like the best example yeah
and they'd be like i'd be like listen
can i get um
a room for the night i like well it's
it's you know 500 bucks a night i'm like
but i'm a i'm a sustainability
consultant and actually want to help out
your hotel
on how to be more like energy efficient
and optimize revenues and i have a cost
benefit analysis i had this whole like
manila folder and like
presentation literally go in there and
the manager would like sit me down
they'd like usually buy me a meal they
we talk about it they'll be like yeah
i'd love i'd love for you to like
educate and yeah
we'll give you we'll give you a couple
nights in our you know that's how i
would like leverage that
was it just a template that you would
take to every hotel i would
switch it to like based on their like
prices and everything i see yeah so
you're just like a template and i'm not
a math person
okay i couldn't graduate college because
i couldn't pass it right um
you could sell this template to other
people one of these distinctively
you can solve it imagine all of all of
the subscribers who's just like hey
sustainability consultant like you're
the tenth person that's a week that's
getting this hotel
the fifth person today and we take our
rooms
no i mean i feel like especially when
you're traveling internationally
the like they want you like you're
coming from america
you know and you are coming from
educational degree like or some sort of
educational background
and so they kind of want to they they
see that as being of value and if you
have something to offer
then you know and they're interested in
it
and so that's kind of how i built i
started a website i started my own
business it all failed
but yeah yeah so at this point how much
were you making or was it just
all being funneled back into traveling
it was all being funneled back
like i i would eat bread you worry
financially
what happens if you're homeless in
another country
every every i was like like we didn't
grow up with a lot of money we grew up
with like
moderate you know like i was kind of
used to not growing up with a lot of
money to be able to spend on things
so i was very much used to like and i
was like listen
i'll sleep in train stations i'll sleep
on the sidewalk of like you know
new york city it doesn't matter you know
i would so i would i would sleep on the
sidewalks i would sleep in train
stations and airport it did not matter
at the time
now if i were to do that i'd be like
yeah no no
thanks you know but back then it was
okay and it's what
what i was prepared for essentially um
what made you want to decide to travel
to every country because i'm sure that
was probably
there was a time in your life where you
had to make the decision or you had the
idea of traveling to every single
country like what made you make that
decision
i'd done a lot of travel like prior to
around 25 countries or so
um and i was like you know what i wonder
if i just saw the entire world like
every single country what that would be
like
so it was a passion of mine to see every
single country and
it just kind of sat with me and then
one day i saw at the front page of cnn
there was this really beautiful
guy on it and i was like i'd like com
like just went
went to that article and jack i didn't
know you weren't cnn
you spoiled me yeah and no so this guy
was apparently like on the bachelor
and he did like a little segment i was
like oh wait i've been on naked and
afraid for like a little segment thing
or
or an episode whatever and uh his goal
was to go to every country in the world
and be the fastest person to do it
i was like wow like that is cool
but why is he on the front page and his
name was eric hill
and he was like 50 countries in and he
was paragliding in utah i think he was
from utah
um and he went into a i don't want to
he he he died unfortunately he died
and he was like 32 is gorgeous i thought
he was my number one like in life yeah i
really thought we were gonna be married
that was so terrible
we're meant to be together and then i
saw that and i was like
well and so i actually talked to his
family and stuff they're like well we're
really glad you're talking about his
legacy and spreading that because i was
taught that's like
it that's how i found out about the
guinness world record essentially and
like that
wow this is possible you know jeez
yeah they're the only other guy to break
um to do this record that i did was
um he did it in like uh i don't know
like three years
and 10 months or something yeah but how
long did it take you
it took me 18 months and 10 days wow
really quickly what's the current record
so actually there have been
uh there's there's a girl who broke it
and she did it in like 18 months and
like a little less than that how
difficult is that to do i mean if if you
had a few hundred grand
could you just knock this out in a year
and then you take a
world record that's a good question
because i feel like a lot of people
um it depends on your passport
uh where you're from and if you can get
those certain last visas
like yemen turkmenistan uh syria
pakistan and it's kind of like in their
hands
and when i was finished it was like 2017
i finished like in february
but i went through the whole election
like with trump you know
and he the last like
week i was finishing he had that
sanction where people
you know citizens of uh iraq iran there
were like four countries yeah yemen was
one of them
couldn't travel to the us so they put
that ban on for people from the us
couldn't travel to their countries
and i was about to travel to yemen as my
last country i was like
i was like sweat i can't imagine just
doing this and then i'm not
was like incredible plus it's like
really hard to get there as an american
they're like
if you go to the u.s embassy in um oman
they're gonna be like well
if you go into yemen we have absolutely
no liability over you and that you're
in there yourself like we cannot get you
out even if you have like anything we
cannot get you out
and so i was like that's fine i got i
got to go there but like
with that happening and that and i was
like oh god i
ended up doing it just in time before
they realized that he had that sanction
could you just step in the airport what
counts is you visiting a country it's
just like you just step in the airport
like come here
get back in the plane yeah uh you have
to go past
border control and baggage claim like
you have to
go through like border control get your
passport stamped which usually requires
you to like go outside the airport
so you essentially like i went south i
went outside the airport in every
country so like
that right for guinness that's what was
required for that yeah how many
countries have you been to where it's
just
outside the airport and then go right
back uh around like 15.
okay which countries or just a couple
like off the uh
nauru was one of them haven't heard of
that yeah why
is it the time reasons or safety it was
budget budget
because i had a huge budget i had to
adhere to like and make sure that
and a lot of those countries were in
africa too because africa is really
expensive to travel to believe it or not
why the flights to get there since
there's no there's not a lot of options
with
hotels and whatnot and food and they
have to like import everything
to like central africa you know western
africa
you have to kind of like really budget
for those hotels
and the food and everything and the
flights are really like
really expensive um they have almost the
same amount of countries as europe
but europe is so much cheaper because
it's so much smaller like easier to get
around and plus
like it's more modernized industrialized
um
yeah some of those pacific islands like
nauru tuvalu
um i've heard of two below chad
chad i see it in night i've ever tried
you're saying chad trying to stay
tonight
um burkina faso i like stayed tonight i
mean there was
you know jed's better than kyle
[Laughter]
dad joke
i wonder if there isn't the thing is
though
there's over 350 countries like if you
count territories and colonies so like
puerto rico's owned by the us
i didn't go to scotland or wales because
they're owned by like the uk um
so there's over there's a ton of
countries out there and maybe
there's a personally named kylean
who knows is there anywhere left that
you'd want to go
at this point i want to go to the north
pole
i want to go to like french polynesia
too really bad
why the north pole in it it's south pole
antarctica because i kind of i've been
there before
in the south yeah so i kind of want to
see like the north and
the polar bears are not in antarctica or
anything
got it what was the cheapest place
that you visited oh i like this one like
if graham were to go travel somewhere if
i'm gonna travel
yeah where would you suggest he goes
okay
um i would say
like indonesia thailand vietnam
cambodia lao that was really cheap those
are very cheap countries
i think those are probably the cheapest
i've been to
and flight wise too there's some really
good deals where you can fly
round trip like 400 bucks and then wow
luxury hotel like 80 bucks yeah are you
serious oh yeah graham knows this summer
i actually since i've never really
traveled before yeah i decided it was
finally time i'm taking matters into my
own hands
and i bought i remember the tickets to
thailand yeah with my best friend jack
awesome and we we bought the tickets
and of course the illness
yeah is that is that refundable yeah
yeah because i bought uh insurance
lucky it was only 550
or so yeah for thailand but we already
booked like an airbnb and stuff wow
and i was looking up a lot of the stuff
about like the culture of thailand
and stuff is crazy like like street food
you can go and there's just these
markets with a bunch of little tents and
people just serve out the street food
it's like of the equivalent of like one
dollar and fifty cents for these crazy
like
really high meals yeah you're like
living back right
wait how old are you i'm 21.
i thought you were in your like your
late 20s or so
no i'm like you're speaking
i'm like wow i'm like living through how
i feel like i was like when i was it's
true it's true but it's so exciting and
then
once you hit 30 it's like oh things have
changed
yeah how is it less exciting at 30
though just
i feel like you're more for me
personally i'm more into business
and less into exploration i guess okay
maybe that's because you've already
explored
right that could be it that's right true
true true but
i i find like business development
really exciting right now
and so when trying to connect with like
younger people that euphoria
that they have that i used to have i'm
like okay bring yourself back to their
cass you once were there
and now you're more into like a stagnant
business
boring sense which for you isn't boring
no i don't know but in a way life kind
of hits you over the head
and then you get used to certain things
and nothing is just new because because
in the beginning you always have this
big newness over everything it's like
all the exciting possibilities and then
things settle down and and it is what it
is that's the right thing happens
you get a cat now it's the idea of
leaving that going too far from the
house
yeah i don't like it no i can't leave
without you anymore yeah like
if i get a free trip to like border
board i'm like i have to bring him with
me yeah and like i got a trip to iceland
i'm like can i bring my
they're like no i'm like well i can't
catch
wow you know use it on someone who
really wants like you would love to you
know what i'm saying yeah i
where send me yeah give these people my
contacts
can work from there so okay so let's
talk about the
your favorite places to go top five okay
um pakistan why
pakistan it is so different than
any other country i've ever been to it's
also like
i was like do i like india or do i like
the like i love the middle eastern
region like i love it
that's my favorite region but um it's so
kind of like
taboo too to go there uh
i don't know how much i'm gonna get into
because the algorithm yeah
youtube but um it ends it's just such an
interesting place and the food is
totally different from like
india or the middle east and the people
are so actually you don't have to like
wear hijab or
burka as a woman like you don't have to
cover up or anything i mean
as much and i just found it to be a
really plus you have like the mountains
and like
it's a really cool spot the mountains in
the beach and it's like
california is like the mountains in the
beach and i just i don't know i love
pakistan personally okay
uh very interesting culture um
uh mongolia is another good spot hmm
mongolia you know what i'm a nature girl
i like the barbecue
have you had them right yeah oh yeah of
course yeah yeah of course yeah oh you
gotta go sometime
in l.a yes my favorite country is the us
because you can find all this stuff oh
i'm sure
you know yeah that's why it's my
favorite okay but um
mongolia is incredible um yeah i mean i
love peru
peru is definitely a top costa rica is
another top
streak is really pretty and i really
liked oman
you know middle eastern okay these are
not traditional like
i could easily just say like you know
france or
you know greece or whatnot but like
these are the
like non-traditional and new zealand was
a really cool one as well
it's hard to pick a top five though
honestly it's
and what okay least favorite yeah what
place is this incredible
okay experience
yay where is bhutan because bhutan is
like right above some people may not
know
nepal and like um you have uh
like in between like china and nepal uh
tibet
and nepal moreover um and
they just like you arrive and there is
like i don't know if this is youtube
friendly but you just
yeah we'll see yeah there's like weed
growing everywhere and like oh my tour
guide and you have to have it's like 250
bucks a day you have to get a tour guide
it's like look there's like marijuana
growing everywhere and i was like oh
cool he's like we don't touch it though
like we don't
we just let it grow and then you like
the buildings like any building you
drive by there are these
beautiful like big gorgeous painted like
huge take up the whole building like
why i don't leave that out jack yeah why
would
a phallic organization
the kids like second grade they all draw
that yeah
they're actually saints it's like a
cloud forest it's like really beautiful
over there like it's a stunning spot if
you're gonna go
like a really that's a really one that's
a winner for sure huh yeah
wow okay so other least favorite
no no that was her favorite that was
just one of my favorites oh yeah
yeah that sounds really cool
um least favorite i hate to say of it it
was italy
why to this very day um
because the men and as a woman
the men it was a huge issue i've never
been able to get past it
no i've been there like six times my
last name is italian actually my great
grandpa
was from italy um but the men just like
the cat calling and everything it's
absolutely
it's something that i can't get past
i've worked a lot of the work aways i
did when i was younger in my early 20s
was for
you know airbnb not airbnb's didn't
exist it was like bed and breakfast
and like like hotels or whatever and the
owners were these like men and they just
like make me do a bunch of stuff and
like it was absolutely terrible and it
was only in italy like i didn't
experience that anywhere else
so yeah but i mean for you guys it's
fine i mean everything else about italy
is
incredible you know the food and the
everything what about other places you
didn't like
um i mean i would say
um it depends on like
like how the not like situation is
because
it's hard with what they're going
through but i mean
south sudan isn't a place to really
visit unless you're going to help them
in somalia
so like you know those places aren't
really
it's a heart that's a loaded question no
it's like just like a place where you
have a good time yeah and it would it
wouldn't make sense
if they were going through something
that maybe you yeah yeah i mean burkina
faso was a country where like
i was you know i allocated a certain
amount of funds to spend
in countries where i knew that i had to
be a little bit safer
as a woman so like with hotels or
whatnot so this one in burkina faso i
spent like 100 bucks or whatnot
and like it was 2 a.m and i was like
sleeping there like nate because i had
like a little backpack i didn't care i
had like one outfit
and a guy open like use a swipe key and
open my
room like open my door you know at 2 am
wow and i just saw this figure i didn't
have my glasses on i couldn't find them
i was about to go find them because i
was like
totally like barenaked and i was like
how am i and they speak french there and
i was like
what no like get out get out of here get
out of here you know and it was like
really scary because he could have
totally done whatever
and i realized that he was like a part
of the staff of that hotel
they were all men at the concierge like
at the front desk everyone like it was a
man-owned hotel essentially
and um but that was just like a hotel
was that a mistake
that was a mistake he did it on purpose
yeah and he and he was looking at me
but do you think that maybe he's just
trying to like take it out
yeah like just just like it took a few
it took a few times
yeah but he like i think he had
intentions but he left
he left okay because i was like
screaming wow i mean
that's horrifying i'm sorry i don't know
honestly i think you can find the good
in every single country
i know that sounds boring but like it's
just like going into
each country with a completely open mind
and like leaving all preconceptions at
the door and just like formulating your
own experience
i think is really important from my
experience both those experiences were
like
coming from a woman but you guys
probably wouldn't experience those so
it's kind of
right you know i mean i feel like
there's no country
to not even north korea like that was
that was a great experience i mean
do that like it's easy to go actually
but
don't you have to be monitored like you
yes yeah so you have like tour guides
and stuff
that makes sure you don't exactly line
exactly
yeah what questions you have prepared
for us jack me
i have plenty let's see plenty of
questions
typically i prepare questions and we
just somehow organically
arrive i know that first one i was like
ooh
too fresh what i forget the first one i
think it was about money with the trip
okay that's a whole other thing with
that why would you
you don't want to discuss that oh i can
talk about it for sure but i just don't
think i was like ready to plunge into it
let's plunge into it now okay so the
money things are the truth
is your money your money i don't want to
like i want you people want what they
want
right people want you to talk about
money okay so yeah so let's dive into it
yeah
would we first off
i mean close enough to the truth where
we could make the title like
how she traveled the world for free
or is that not true not at all um
well because essentially like i had
investors and sponsors so i don't know
if that's free
but it didn't come out of your pocket
only around like 10 grand dead
how do we travel the entire world for 10
000. mention that somewhere in the video
so we could use that as a title so how
much did it cost
to travel the entire world yeah what was
your total out-of-pocket cost
out-of-pocket yeah out-of-pocket costs
were around 10 grand
yeah wow that's impressive yeah that's
very
we came up with their title now yeah but
what was this money thing that you were
saying you didn't want to dive into it
in the beginning
is that this uh well it's it's a whole
other aspect of the expedition that
and travel in general but like so i've
had two sets of travel like in my early
20s than my expedition
so i'm talking about my expedition now
but um it's just like there's a whole
there's so many layers to it that okay
i'm wildly impressed that you traveled
the world for 10 grand
if i had the opportunity to travel the
world return grand
i probably i mean not right now because
of graham but i
most definitely would otherwise and
that's very very cool so
essentially you saved up some money from
babysitting and from
being a lifeguard and then you use that
money to have your initial
expedition and then you came back and
decided
that you wanted to travel the entire
world and break a guinness world record
no close though okay plus a couple
points very close
very close i would give you three out of
out of ten
on that one no i just want to be 60 to
30.
well i'm not good with math you guys
yeah so maybe three out of five three
out of five
okay so what was wrong no so so
i essentially took that 10 grand and
started traveling the world but
i had a plan in place and i had sponsors
and investors
okay to get going with that as well how
do you get
sponsors and investors yeah so i had to
do a lot of networking so i go to like
c-level
travel events like travel and tourism
you know conferences
the stuff that would like eat at me
because i'm such an introvert but i had
to just go and
and just pitch myself essentially as
much as possible
to these like one of them is yeah mm-hmm
oh sorry oh
i had a question yeah yeah you can go
ahead what's the return on investment
for for a lot of these investors just
honestly to be completely honest
they wanted to give to a young girl who
was
going after like a humanitarian thing
didn't have any money and who was like
working really hard that's
fair enough okay literally like answers
yeah it was a
philanthropic thing all right and also i
was like oh i'll promote you like i'll
talk they're like no i'm like a private
no you do not mention my name
no
these few investors and i met them
face-to-face at these events and i would
like pitch them and i'd be introduced to
them by like other networks that i had
you know like people and so that's what
it was it says that you have two
guinness world records
yes on your website what are what's the
other one
so it's it's the uh fastest person to
visit all sovereign nations
and the fastest female to visit all
sovereign nations
person and female yeah those have been
broken since cool
oh okay but you still have this year
yeah i have the plaques and everything
they can't take those away from you
no no are those like framed and they are
totally framed
okay yeah i mean that was my only
accomplishment anyways
any intention of getting that back
though just being like no i'm gonna do
it faster
people have asked that that's like a
huge question but you know what
if i if i had like you know
two mil to do it and fly a business
do you think i could do that for two
million dollars and just be the fastest
um how much is it going to cut if
someone watching this right now is being
like no i'm going to get that record how
much would it cost
uh 100 grand you could do it you could
do it for a hundred grand but the thing
is
there's so many variables like your
passport and if you can get the visa
that's dependent on the embassy like
literally i had to go back and forth
to the pakistani embassy like five times
be like please
please issue me this visa and
turkmenistan is like a guessing game
like they deny
just random people can you tell them
about this or would that make it worse
sometimes
we don't want to be a part of this
american trump girl
yeah okay are you allowed to use a trip
advisor
like yeah yeah i use trip advisor a lot
trip advisor or a trip advisor is there
oh you can use
yeah yeah like a trip planner or what so
yeah i had that for
some of my visas for sure yeah okay
santa's vagabond
because that would probably take care of
a lot of it would help they helped a lot
of people because yeah i feel like
getting like expedia like booking.com or
something like that would be
great yeah i went to one of the summits
i went to
in between my expedition was a world
travel tourism council summit
and i was flying back i got sponsored
there to fly business it was my first
time ever flying business class okay and
i was super excited
on the way back it was in madrid um my
seat mate
was the ceo of expedia um at the time
his name began with the d i don't
remember my i'm really about names sure
he was sitting next to me i was like
i've been wanting to pitch this guy
the whole weekend he was on my list i've
been watching so i'm like i'm like
trying to stay chill
but i was so hungover from our last
night they got me really
wild up wow but the whole time
i was back and forth between the toilet
no the plane
i didn't have enough energy to even
pitch myself to this
guy and we were right next to each other
it was like
why did you drink that's why i don't
yeah we don't mess with that stuff
yeah they wanted you to say
you don't drink the the the owner of the
you know his son and like they're like
oh i'll introduce you and hear some more
and i'm like
listen you can't not comply i feel like
it's hard in madrid where there's like
you have one drink two masks that's
it listen i'm not good with it i'm not
good with it it's really bad but i'm not
good with that and
that totally messed up that deal because
then he just i think he bought out like
orbits too and i was like
missed opportunity you know what you
live on another flight though
i was like waiting in line for the
bathroom in economy and this guy was
behind me and this is like also right
before my expedition
i was like hey you look like that guy
toby from the office
no and i was drinking too so i was also
more open
with speaking yeah that was this is when
it actually helped me
wow and he's like yeah i'm paul
liberstein
yeah from the office yes i was like
hey i'm going this extra expedition
around the world would you be interested
in like being a supporter
on it he's like yeah for sure i'm
sending the information so he was a
supporter of my so i ended up
honoring you that is so cool you know
that wouldn't
like contribute anything but they'd just
be like on my website which was
really cool that's neat yeah wow
okay i like toby yeah good guy yeah he's
awesome yeah
he's yeah he's he's is he the same
personality in person
uh he's a little more chill i don't know
who's he's more chilling for like he
seems
so really relaxed he was so relaxed
though yeah yeah i would say he's pretty
similar
hey hey guys yeah yeah hey my god
yeah like that i don't know hit a little
more of herself okay
hey cassie
he was chill yeah and honestly
in economy i was like to look back and
be like huh
yeah that's cool wait so he was flying
economy
i guess so wow it was like delta i don't
know
that's cool you know i saw i was
actually on a flight
coming from uh where was it it was
either
i think it was canada toronto and up in
first class
was that guy from two and a half men not
charlie shane but the other guy
huh i never watched it yeah i feel like
i know who you're talking about
he shaved his head now he's a villain oh
the austin powers guy no no it's mike
myers dude
no no the villain austin powers the
that's mike myers
what yes he plays the same character
that's the whole point he's serious
do you not know that the million dollars
guy
yeah dr evil that's all him he plays
like most of the characters in the movie
this is this is real guys i don't know
don't ask me are you
serious how am i supposed to know that
they look completely different that's
the point of makeup
is it john cryer john cryer is who
i flew on a plane with that that guy oh
yeah yeah yeah okay yeah yeah for sure
yeah okay john cryer but come on man
look mike myers
mike meyer's character it looks
completely different
who stays and watches the credits to see
to see like dr evil mike myers
they sound the same he was he was also a
fat bastard
did you think that was an actor too yeah
like a different actor
that was like not him wow yeah he's he
plays
you see you're surprised yeah i know
he's crazy i don't know he also plays
mini me no he doesn't that's
i know that's that's someone else
kidding kidding that was a joke
but yeah no those are all of his
character it looks the same
no it doesn't they do the face
does that face that looks like mike
meyer's face the eyes
the eyes oh my god the eyes oh my god it
does
though it really dies you can't even see
the eyes in that picture
you can't even see the eyes it's just a
blur just saying those are all of his
characters it's like eddie murphy
playing all the you know all these
characters in the nutty professor
i entertain it when i actually the last
travel i went on was in
uh march and i was coming back from
british columbia to l.a
and i was in business because for
speaking engagement and like
one of the guys like got up and like and
started like packing up all this toilet
paper
and i like made a joke because i'd had
some wine and uh
obvious because it makes you more open
okay otherwise you wouldn't say this and
no one did i was like well that's a lot
of toilet paper you have and
everyone turned to me and they're like
because they were all like wanting to
say something to him i guess
i guess he was a really big actor um
i couldn't tell you who he was right now
because i forgot but like i don't know
but like they all did everyone in like
business you're probably saying what
everyone else wanted and then they all
picked up on my conversation
with him in the toilet paper why do you
have so much toilet paper
because it was the quarantine and so
he's like my wife in l.a they were out
so he had to bring it back so he had to
defend himself like it's okay
it's okay okay it's my wife not me yeah
but okay have you ever traveled out of
the country graham
canada oh canada and mexico okay cool
yeah that's it so i haven't left the
continent though okay
well technically i've been to canada and
mexico i went to alaska and i think
there was a layover or something
probably but i was
10 and i don't remember i i literally
think we were only in the airport
in canada and then there was a cruise
down in mexico that it was like five but
i don't think we ever actually docked
so okay technically i have been out of
the country i'm
quite exotic all right yeah cool yeah
well it takes money
you know and it takes you know time off
of work time
that's all unless you can travel
influencer
yeah unless you could freeze time and
just go and travel and come back and not
miss anything
yeah it's just the time aspect of it or
where would you go
um probably australia
fiji snorkeling spots love to do
snorkeling spots
aquarium reef yeah yeah so the great
barrier reef
fiji i think um what's the one
the malt dives oh i was gonna say i was
just gonna say my lives are safe shells
but like
right yeah stuff like that like beachy
tropical places where i can go scuba
diving i think and if you guys ever need
someone to watch your cat you know
deal mm-hmm he's a cat lady here yeah so
can you tell us now i think this is a
good
segue into how much you spend every
month okay
do you drink starbucks oh no i make my
own coffee
okay yeah so how much do you spend every
month and then where do you waste your
money and then how much do you make
every month
your household income net worth credit
score
investments not prepare for any of these
oh and then how much money you have in
investments and how much this oh my god
does this
make you have you read the market oh my
god
i'm just a travel girl your best
investment and your worst investment
go oh no no there's there's a lot of
yeah i'm not i will say as much as i'm
not proud i'm not a money girl
okay i'm not i wasn't right like my
parents weren't good with money
we didn't grow up with a lot of money it
was kind of like we never really learned
about money
and so i was just
making not a lot of like around like
like i said like 40 grand
babysitting you know and then so i
didn't really start making money until
around three years ago
you know like 27 when this all finished
and suddenly i was like in the
you know six-figure ish up
range and i want to be vague because i
feel like yeah sure
yeah yeah but um and it just like went
from zero to nothing
and i was like how do i manage this
first of all i have to invest it into
the business like
everything has gone into the business
the past few years um
and so it wasn't really until like the
past
really quarantined that i was like huh
stocks
my brother's like i'm looking into
trading and day trading and i'm like
oh maybe i should do and then your
videos are like oh i should maybe look
at
some stocks and investing so i'm like
yeah i'm budgeting though
yeah i budget you start to budget okay
for sure for sure what's your savings
rate
my savings percentage
each paycheck okay should be higher well
it depends
like i'm sure it should be well okay so
what do you say
but we're talking about investing too
okay should be
sure should be 30. we're going to get
that to 30 30
i can get there okay yeah i feel like
i'm just so new with like making a good
amount of money
that i'm like i've had to just focus on
growing the business and i haven't
really
thought about because i wasn't really
educated on that yeah you know
like investing um and so now i'm doing
like real estate like land development
um and just really i'm growing in like
many ways but
to to invest if you get a better roi
investing in yourself and your business
it only makes sense to
i agree with continue doing that yeah
where do you waste money
um i may air one
no not if you go every day if you go
every day
but they put all memberships on hold
starting uh march
yeah i cancelled right the arrow one is
the biggest waste of money that that
that i think is a scam store
what percentage of stamina do you pay
just based on arrows
yeah one of equinox or equinox i'm a
member but like
erwan are you no oh gosh no i've been in
the store a few times just to look at
the prices yeah
it double oh yeah everything double so
it's a double 100 percent yeah i
remember i walked in there
and they had like a little thing of
watermelon like this size it's filled
with watermelon slices
it's like nine dollars yeah like to buy
a full watermelon is maybe like three
bucks
yeah and you're getting a slice of
watermelon yes
for nine dollars and they also had these
like pre-made sandwiches
that you would think in any normal store
would cost like four bucks five bucks
yeah these sandwiches like 16 dollars
for a little pre-made sandwich why don't
you just go to a restaurant
and get a sandwich that's totally
different it was the juices they had
like this juice
cleanse thing these little shots of
things are five six bucks
or like these smoothies for like twelve
dollars it's it's
everything's like kombucha insane they
just
wow oh and the chocolates they have
these like seven dollar chunks get away
with that
because people is with money good or
like want to feel
superior and they want to be like i'm
getting the highest quality stuff
i like money can possibly guy money is
no object
but what they're really getting is
ripped off that's that's what they're
getting
it's true i've spent like 150 i've spent
450
on a bag of of groceries at air won and
they would fit one third
the bag because the supplements and
everything there mm-hmm and then i go to
trader joe's and for 130 get like eight
oh yeah
oh yeah that's the only place i go now
in calabasas yeah trader joe's is good
but not around
oh and and even airlines sometimes some
of the most of them actually
i think have valet so you could go and
valet your car at the grocery store
it's fancy oh i've never been there yeah
you're 21.
yeah i mean part of me wants to go there
and film it but i have a feeling if we
walk in
with a camera we should do a trip to air
one okay
you should you should do that that'd be
really interesting reaction
millionaire reacts to arrow
entertainment yeah
we could do we could do that but the
thing is you go in with a camera you'll
for sure get kicked out
you would have to do it so indiscreetly
with like an iphone or something
and the palisades one is a really good
one to do that i'd say okay
yeah that's a good one okay let's put
that on that to-do list
waste of money but yeah it's a splurge
for sure yeah
we could just do that with an iphone
that could be an episode on like a
weekend go to arrow on and just just
react
rip on air on every time after equinox
like i would go
that's now during combining like two of
the most expensive things like after the
equinox
plus you'd have to pay for parking
equinox if you're over like two hours or
something or an hour
it was it's like i'd always like be
there for like two years you don't have
to pay for parking if you're overwhelmed
you do have to pay for parking yeah in
santa monica you have to
were you did you go in santa monica yeah
it was like you'd have to pay like over
two hours oh you have to pay why
wouldn't they give you free parking
if you're paying like it's free for two
hours up to two hours but like
if you're going to shower or if you want
to like do a bunch of if you're really
muscular if you're graham you know you
want to stay there for
two hours i spent all day there yeah i
break the machines and i'm like
he goes until they break actually shelby
just
shul she just sold me on that machine
oh yeah okay cool the two thousand
dollar one i know but i know but
well i need weights and like i can't
find them anywhere
online it's like for a whole set it's
like 2 000. i'm like okay well
you know what you got to do me as well
is you got to join graham and i cause we
go on these runs every day
and we run to a childhood like we run to
a children's playground
this is every day and we do pull-ups on
the monkey bars or whatever like it's
empty there's no one there
well they're they're closed but you just
want i mean there's literally
no one there there's no we just do
pull-ups on a children's plan yeah it's
good though but you do different ones
you do different like like the the
pull-ups at different
uh lengths well graham's better than the
other ones yeah he's good yeah
that's a good back workout and then you
get a run at the same time
huh just go to a children's program have
everything you need
yeah that's a good idea i should think
about but i've already bought it
yeah two ways yeah let's do this let's
use it
let's ask the duck horse question well
one you can ask it
okay um so the last question we we leave
everyone with it's probably going to
cause many nights of sleeplessness
would you rather fight 100
duck-sized horses or one horse-sized
duck
i'd probably do the big the big duck
you'd rather the one big duck why
um because i know some krav maga and i
feel like i could
take krav maga okay
all right cool okay good answer let's
wrap it up
cool i guess thanks for having me yeah
thank you so much for coming on
so much really appreciate it as always
guys make sure to destroy the like
button subscribe button notification
bell we'll put instagrams down below in
the description
get your two free stocks from weeble
because now one of those stocks is going
to be worth all the way to 1
600 how crazy is that 1600 bucks
up to fine print there but anyway thank
you guys so much for watching really
appreciate it and until
next time
around 10 grand uh in that like year and
a half before
once i decided to do this expedition i
started i gotta save
what wait did i
no success
you do the intro